Alright guys, so here is an example number two.
So I'm looking at NCDUSD on the daily timeframe.
As you can see, we took out this external liquidity which is this high over here and our draw
on liquidity would be this fair value gap.
But let's go to the one over time frame and see what happened.
So price took out the liquidity here, right?
Now price is in our POI.
So now essentially what we are waiting for is we have to identify original consolidation.
So where's the original consolidation?
In my eyes, it's right here.
You can see we went up and down from here, but then we have a small consolidation here
giving us two consolidations, right?
And when price came back into our POI, took out liquidity, we had a shift in the market
structure and right away what we have is an auto block for these consecutive bullish
candles.
We have this fair value gap.
Now price goes down, goes down, goes down.
You can see there is an auto block here, right?
Remember the mitigation blocks.
So this bearish candle, price broke through that.
What do we have inside it?
A bearish auto block, price taps into that bearish auto block.
Then we have what?
Another mitigation block, price breaks through this, but do we have fair value gap?
Of course price went a little higher from here because this is not a clean high.
So our stop would be here because that is a high.
Higher highs are the highest candle is the mid one and the left and the right candle
is the lowest like from this week.
And as you can see, the price is currently on its way down to take out this low here.
And it eventually will because this is the original consolidation.
As you can see, when price like started moving up, right, or you could just simply say like
this is one big consolidation phase right there.
Yeah.
So maybe we can just take out this level here as well.
We have a tiny consolidation here as well and pretty much it sums up everything that
I've thought right now.
So let's move on to the next example.